Now in economics and in game theory, the value of a state is called its utility.
It's just a number.
So we're at the end of the game, and if there's 1 state where we win,
we'll give that a utility of 1.
If there's another state where we lose, we'll give that a utility of 0.
Now if I have a choice here--it's my turn to move--I have a choice to go either way.
I'm going to maximize my choice, and I'm going to move there.
That means the utility of this state is going to be 1 because I know I can get 1
by taking the optimal strategy.
We keep backing up the tree that way.
That's if it was my choice here.
If it was my opponent's choice, and they could go in either way,
then my opponent is going to minimize my score or maximize their score
and go in this direction, forcing me to lose and allowing them to win.
So we'll say the utility of this state is 0 for me.
And I want to also introduce here another idea called the quality,
which is the function on a state and an action and gives us a number--a utility number.
So that's saying, what's the quality of this action in this particular state?
So if these were the actions, hold and roll, then we'd say for my opponent
the quality of rolling from this state would give us this utility,
and the quality of holding would give us this utility.
Finally, if it was the dice's turn--and let's say there are 6 outcomes, but 3 of them
lead to this state and 3 of them lead to this state--
then from the dice we're going to average over all the possibilities,
so it's half of one and half of 0, so the utility of this state is 1/2.
So now we have a way--if we know the value of the end states,
which is defined by the game, defined by when we win and lose and how many points
each player gets for that--
now we have a way of essentially searching backwards to say, from the end state,
I can go backwards and say, what's the value of one of my moves?
Oh! I know that. It's the maximum.
What's the value of my opponents? I know that. It's the minimum.
What's the value of a random dice roll?
I know that. It's the average.
Now we could go all the way back, backing up the tree to say,
what's the value of this start state?
I can collect those values, and I can have a utility for this start state,
and we'll see--in the game of pig--the start state for the first player has a little bit better
than 50% chance just because they go first.
For the game we defined, I think it works out to about 54%--
.54 utility for the player who goes first.
We can also work out the quality for each of these moves.
We can work out, what's the quality of rolling from this state,
and what's the quality of holding from this state,
and then the optimal strategy is just the one that says choose the move
which has the highest quality.
If roll has the highest quality from this state, then that's the move that we should do.
So just as we did in search, we're finding our way from the start to the goal.
We can do that with a random problems,
but we have to find a way not to just 1 individual outcome,
but to all the outcomes that were covered by all the possibility of the dice.
So the complications going to be more complex, but the idea is the same.